des images d'une ville presque désertes
des rideaux encore fermée plus que
quelques heures avant une réouverture
des commerces non essentiels très
attendu les commerces belge désemparé
perdu à l'issue de ce deuxième
confinement le premier confinement on
était vu comme un magasin non essentiels
dont elles nous ont fermé durant deux
mois
là ils nous ont fermé
pendant quatre jours et après on a eu un
téléphone qui nous disait qu'on pouvait
rouvrir donc pour nos clients s'étaient
pas très clair il ya beaucoup de clients
français qui pensait aussi que les
frontières étaient fermées comme la
première fois mais ce n'est pas le cas
mon lecteur ne m'a rien donné alors je
dois dire mont-blanc des mondiaux au
maire de
devant le rappeur marinette depuis un
mois et puis m'a autorisé autorisé de le
faire parce que je suis tous allons
aussi pendant trois ans que j'habite ici
et kiala commerce délivrance prévu donc
ce mardi 1er décembre mais avec des
contraintes notamment en shopping qui
devra se faire seul est limité trente
minutes
pour le gouvernement il ne doit pas
s'agir d'un shopping de détente en
entendant cette réouverture
la tentation était grande ce week end et
à la proche de noël de traverser la
frontière
l'e commerce français ayant rouvert
depuis samedi je pense que sa va pas
être énorme non plus parce qu'ils disent
tellement dans l'est dans le télé ici
parler en france par leone hollande
je suis déjà longtemps ici dans 36 ans
j'appelle ma clientèle donc un mais
c'est quand même dur hein quand le
malheur des uns fait le petit bonheur
des autres côté français certains
gérants se félicite de cette aubaine
n'est pas bien marché avait fonctionné a
eu du passage parce qu'il ya le marché
pas loin donc il ya eu des gens qui sont
venus et comment acheter
d'électroménager ce matin ils ont
commencé à acheter des jouets de noël à
14 heures quand j'ai ouvert et des
clients aussi pour les jouets de noël
on a eu de la chance parce que nous on y
ait tant que professionnel qu'on avait
le droit donc de circuler et donc j'ai
dû livrer et pas mal donc en belgique ça
nous a ramenés quand même et une
clientèle potentielle
on a du travail quand même allez je
dirais facilement entre 25 et 30% sur
une clientèle dans question de belges en
ce temps de crise sanitaire et malgré la
concurrence la solidarité est aussi
palpable
j'avoue qu'on ouvre on a quand même un
gros pincement encore on pense vraiment
énormément à eux parce qu'on se met dans
l'eure l'avait qu on se fait dans leur
situation est franchement c'est vrai que
il ya rien à comprendre en fait puisque
il franchit cela il traverse la rue ils
sont chez nous et peuvent rentrer dans
le magasin donc ce pas logique
selon la principale fédération belge du
commerce et des services
chaque jour de fermeture représente une
perte de 100 millions d'euros